we're told that cars a b and c are
traveling at constant speeds and they
say select the car that travels the
fastest and we have these three
scenarios here so i encourage you to
pause this video and try to figure out
which of these three cars is traveling
the fastest car a car b or car c
all right now let's work through this
together so car a they clearly just give
its speed it's 50 kilometers per hour
now let's see car b travels the distance
of d kilometers in h hours based on the
equation 55 h is equal to d
all right now let's see if we can
translate this somehow into kilometers
per hour so 55 h is equal to d or we
could say d
is equal to
h and here i'm doing this is this
scenario right over here not scenario a
and so another way to think about it is
distance divided by times if we divide
both sides by hours we would have
distance divided by time
and so
if we have d over h
then we would just be left with 55 on
the right hand side all i did is i
divided both sides
by h
now this is distance divided by time so
the units here are going to be we're
assuming and they tell us d is in
kilometers h is in hours so the units
here are going to be kilometers per
hour
so car b is going 55 kilometers per hour
while car a is only going 50 kilometers
per hour so so far car b is the fastest
now car c travels
135 kilometers in three hours
well let's just get the hourly rate or i
guess you could say the unit rate so
135 kilometers in
in three
hours
and so we can get the rate per hour so
135 divided by 3 is what that is going
to be as you can do in our head it's i
think it's 45 but let me just verify
that 3 goes into 135
3 goes into 13 4 times 4 times 3 is 12
you subtract you get yep 3 goes into 15
5 times 5 times 3 is 15 subtract 0. so
this is equal to 45 kilometers per hour
so car is 50 kilometers per hour car b
is 55 kilometers per hour car c is 45
kilometers per hour so car b
is the fastest